[Music]
hey guys
welcome to our installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing harry potter tom riddle
and the chamber of secrets in the
chamber of secrets we see a much younger
version of voldemort
aka tom riddle inside of the chamber
this version of riddle was of course a
product of his first horcrux
the diary of tom riddle when harry
enters the chamber he's met with riddle
you you're the heir of slytherin your
voldemort
minute by minute the tom riddle in front
of harry appeared more and more real
riddles seemed to grow stronger and
stronger assuming a more prominent
corporeal form
over time he achieved this by feeding
off of ginny
and her deepest and darkest fears she
put too much into the diary
into me enough to let me leave its pages
at last
riddle also later says yes potter the
process is nearly complete
in a few minutes ginny weasley will be
dead and i will cease to be a memory
lord voldemort will return very much
alive
so the chamber of secrets seems to
suggest that the tom riddle in the
chamber
is able to return to some kind of
independent form
additionally he seems to have no issue
casting spells as shown when he casts
flagrante to spell out tom marvolo
riddle
which is then unscrambled into i am lord
voldemort
this made me wonder if voldemort can
cast spells in this form
couldn't he have just killed harry right
then and there wouldn't this have saved
voldemort a lot of grief
why would he sit there while harry
destroys the diary even while fawkes was
healing harry after he got poisoned by
the basilisk
he's just watching and shouting get away
bird
get away from him i said get away this
passive approach is so
un voldemort so why didn't he take more
action to ensure that the boy who lived
became the boy who's dead the answer to
this question
goes back to harry and voldemort's
history the tom riddle that we see in
the chamber is a much younger version of
voldemort
one that does not possess all the
memories that the modern day voldemort
has
this means that he doesn't actually know
the details of how his present-day self
was defeated by harry he knows that
harry is the boy who lived and the
reason for his initial downfall
but he doesn't know how any of it
happened for this reason
it seems fair to assume that he would be
quite apprehensive in his approach to
attacking harry
as he would not want the same thing to
happen twice i have many questions for
you harry potter
like what harry spat fists still
clenched
well said riddle smiling pleasantly how
is it that you
a skinny boy with no extraordinary
magical talent managed to defeat the
greatest wizard of all time
how did you escape with nothing but a
scar while lord voldemort's powers were
destroyed
there was an odd gleam in his hungry
eyes now why do you care how i escaped
was it harry slowly
voldemort said riddle softly is my past
present and future
harry potter to business harry said
riddle
still smiling broadly twice in your past
in my future we have met and twice i
failed to kill you
how did you survive tell me everything
the longer you talk
he added softly the longer you stay
alive so
for this reason seeking the basilisk on
harry seems like the easiest and most
logical choice
if something went awry then it would be
the basilisk that was defeated
and not tom riddle himself however after
harry kills the basilisk
he's poisoned and weak why wouldn't tom
riddle have recognized harry's mortality
at this point and jumped in to finish
him off the answer is of course that
riddle knew that harry was poisoned and
what basilisk's venom was capable of
you're dead harry potter said riddle's
voice above him
dead even dumbledore's bird knows it do
you see what he's doing potter
he's crying i'm going to sit here and
watch you die harry potter
take your time i'm in no hurry so ends
the famous harry potter said riddle's
distant voice
alone in the chamber of secrets forsaken
by his friends
defeated at last by the dark lord he so
unwisely challenged
you'll be back with your dear mud blood
mother soon harry she bought you 12
years of borrowed time
but lord voldemort got you in the end as
you knew he must
riddle knew that harry was doomed and
didn't feel the need to exert any
additional effort to ensure that harry
would die
but once again tom riddle aka
voldemort's arrogance and over-inflated
ego
got the better of him and when he
finally realized what was happening
it was too late for him and that's it
for this video if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel
until next time your wizard harry you